this was mostly  moderates being replaced by moderates so  the effect is that even though joe biden  is replacing people and getting people  confirmed trump  was putting people in that were  primarily ideologically kooky for the  right wing so while joe biden has a high  number for the first year he's replacing  moderates with moderates these are not  ideological nut cases that in any way  they're not ideological ideological not  nut cases on the right they are also not  progressives who are going to push the  judiciary or pull the judiciary back to  the left in any way right this is this  is the the devil's advocate trump was  able to actually change the judiciary  and pull it significantly to the right  and where joe biden is racking up  confirmations they don't really do  anything to undo that because it's  replacing moderates with moderates okay  that that's the kind of pessimistic  devil's advocate perspective